ازدياد البطاله وتراجع الحريات العامه
واغلاق باب الحوار مع النقابات وتاخر
اصدار قوانين تنظم بعض احكام الدستور
واللائحه طويله يقول اقطاب المعارضه
المغربيه وهم يحاولون جرد الحصيله السنويه
لحكومه عبد الاله بن كيران خذنا القياس هو
البرنامج الحكومي
ف الحكومه فشلت مع الاسف في تحقيق
التزاماتها ووعودها للمغاربه على كافه
المستويات فشل حكومي اذا وعلى كل
المستويات هذا ما تؤكده معارضه برلمانيه
اصبح مشعلها في يد حزب الاصاله والمعاصره
بعد الانتخابات الجهويه التي جرت في شهر
سبتمبر ايلول الماضي لكن انتقاد الاصاله
والمعاصره حصيله الحكومه التي يقودها حزب
العداله والتنميه يرى فيه بعض المراقبين
تجنيه على تجربه تمكنت من الحفاظ على
تماسك عناصرها في وضع اقليمي
مضطرب كانت هناك العديد من المحاولات
لتفجير الحكومه من الداخل لكن نجح الحزب
بمعيه حلفائه ومعيه مجموعه من المؤسسات
وعلى راسها المؤسسه الملكيه في ضمان
استقرار هذه التجربه وضمان
استمراريتها استمراريه رسختها اصلاحات
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه يمضي ابن كيران
وحلفائه في اقرارها وعلى راسها اصلاح
منظومه التضامن الاجتماعي ومشروع انقاذ
انظمه المعاشات من الافلاس اضافه الى
النجاح في ضبط الماليه العامه للمملكه
ليبقى التحدي الاكبر هو الحفاظ على
استقرار المؤسسات السياسيه خاصه مع اقتراب
نهايه الولايه التشريعيه مطلع الصيف
القادم تسعه اشهر تفصل المغاربه عن
الانتخابات التشريعيه القادمه انتخابات
ستحدد معالم مرحله جديده من مراحل ما
اصطلح عليه بالاستثناء المغربي في التعاطي
مع تبعات الربيع العربي وفي تدبير شروط
الانتقال
الديمقراطي عبد المنعم العمراني الجزيره
الرباط